hello
folks uh welcome to rational
science and I hope you're doing all
doing better than me I hope you can hear
me well I hope you can see me
well today's my
birthday and I still
congested so not a very good birthday in
that
sense um 71 turn to 71 uh this this is
uh a vision of that okay here it is 71
Revolutions of the Earth around the
Sun that's what I've uh gone
through and some people are so
mean that they remind me of my birthday
they call me up and they say oh it's
your birthday happy birthday oh yeah
thank you you
know thank
you so um yeah I don't know 71 years
it's a long time someone the other I
told him I had arthritis my good friend
Mike and he said you know gave me all
this uh stuff that I should do you know
drink this uh sleep uh whatever do
exercise and I said look I'll follow
I'll I'll do your your recommendations
if you do 71 okay you you do 71 and I'll
do whatever
you you propose okay yeah uh you can't
fight aging you know one of the things
there that I can tell you is that um you
know
um um you've got uh life and you've got
death and people talk about the right to
life and that's not true you know life
is a privilege okay and death is a right
okay we all have the right to die and
you can make uh use of your right to die
any moment you want at your leisure okay
and if you don't do it mother nature
will nudge you and you know lead you the
way okay but uh life life is a privilege
okay so there's no right to life and
just keep that in mind and similarly
along the same lines you know people say
oh I have the right to vote no voting is
not a right okay voting is not a right
uh uh voting uh being a right is like
you asking me for an autograph is a
right for me it's whim you know if I
want to I give you my autograph uh for
you it's a privilege you know right
doesn't play any role either way and so
people have to Define these terms and
really understand them
and
King okay uh and um oneall sent me a
little note and he said the following he
says gaty proven right again what was he
talking about well I define marriage way
back uh as One bank account that's
that's marriage okay One bank account
and he he found this article on the Wall
Street Journal says our joint bank
accounts uh the secret to a happy
marriage and says not only are couples
who merge finances more satisfied with
their relationship they are more likely
to be on the same page about money
issues according to a
study and yeah uh it's U what you can
say is that marriage is a single bank
account and if you don't uh have a
single bank account uh well then uh you
know you you're you're not married
let me get this out of
here you're not married okay if if you
you know if you have two Banks accounts
you have this situation when you when
you get married or when you take your
vows okay uh this is the two bank
account version of you know your vow
marriage vow uh divorce do us part
you're guarantee that you're going to
separate from your woman or woman from a
man right because each one has his own
thing everybody's ready to
run okay so two bank accounts is a uh a
guaranteed um setup from the start for
divorce or for separation or whatever
you know I've been married and going on
48 years we've had a great marriage with
my wife ups and downs we had a lot of
Adventures and I can only wish other
people to have a similar luck you know
it's not easy to carry um to be married
you know and uh nobody is U
trained or educated to be married or to
be a father a mother or you know husband
wife uh even a son if you come to think
of it you know nobody's trained to do
that you kind of learn as you go
along time goes by and uh so all I can
say is I wish other people the same luck
I've had you know as far as marriage is
concerned okay anyways I'm a little
congested so I took put some drops in
there uh so that you know I don't speak
like some drops you in my doze so um I
can breathe a little better but yeah I'm
not over my congestion came back from
vacation like that okay let's get
started we're going to start with
Extinction again and we had uh this
situation where I uh sometime back I put
this little article that came out
regarding
um yeah uh we had um a little article
where the um chimps some chimps troop of
chimps maybe a hundred chimps were found
to have more genetic diversity within
that troop than all of the human race
than or you know seven eight billion
people and you say how can that be and
the article was something like this
let's see if I can get it up
here
uh give me a second here see if I can
get it in there no I don't have the
article okay anyways the point here is
that uh there was an article that said
uh a study right then again uh
everybody's uh depends on whether do you
believe some of these studies out there
but they did a DNA analysis of a troop
of chimps out there in Africa and they
found and they and several uh people did
it you know separately several groups
and they ended up convinced that uh this
troop had more genetic diversity than
all the human race and they could not
explain it they said with 8 billion
people you would think that you know we
create uh new uh genetics every day you
know we there's mutations going on every
day and the question is why you know and
so one fell asked me about that and he
says the following he says uh so what is
the explanation for chimp's higher
diversity if they also inbreed because
I'm saying you know inbreeding
reduces uh genetic diversity over the
thousands of years right so for any
species that's uh been around for quite
a while you lose
genetic diversity not gain it and even
though you accumulate
mutations uh periodically daily minutely
whatever um it doesn't for some reason
we lose it right and so here are my
takes on that okay uh you got to look at
where a species is in its
history you know uh if you grab a
species for example if you knew that
this species is going to die in the next
100,000 years um maybe they've been
around for only 100,000 years and you're
looking at you know the midpoint and so
they haven't had time to lose their
genetic diversity because they still
have 100,000 more years to go for
whatever reason right um and so the
question is are we at the beginning of
our species life span or are we close to
the end and you know my answer to that
we're close to the end very close
uh it's how fast also um a species
conquer
diseases you know uh chimps are in a
given region of the planet they don't
they have at least they don't migrate
today and they haven't migrated they're
always there and so they're localized uh
the question is whether all these chimps
have had a chance to meet different
kinds of diseases that would um um sift
it out
those chimps that did not have natural
defenses and create you know a more
uniform group of chimps and again that's
got to do also with time okay so there's
two things going on in there and then
again you know migration
um when species migrate they encounter
new obstacles new uh Predators or prey
uh new diseases and it takes a long time
to adapt to them okay and so um you know
again uh if a chimp if the chimps were
more or less always in the same region
they haven't had a chance to you know be
challenged uh from a genetic point of
view those are my general takes on that
here's a graph that shows us I put that
in my yandal book okay and it's more or
less like this mutation rate increases
as the group adaps adapts to new
diseases climates Foods Predators Etc so
you have you know a group that branches
off from the mother trunk and it has to
adapt to a certain region it becomes
isolated from the mother trunk and
throughout this initial period they gain
genetic diversity but then over time uh
they lose it because despite the fact
that you know they have um Founders
effects and bottle next uh you know that
that whittles out some of the uh
diversity from from the whole population
and it's not a smooth curve as you see
there it's really ups and downs because
of you know these factors okay here's
what it looks like uh for humans this is
our uh curve uh compared also with a
population curve there you can see that
for most of our um lifespan we were a
very small population
and uh you know and the genetic
diversity dropped gradually okay
throughout this time and it was only and
because we were primarily Hunter gathers
we were moving around we were
encountering new diseases new Predators
we had to adapt and these are you know
this takes thousands of years when we
got to agriculture we more or less
settled down even though we were still
colonizing the land okay and it was only
in the last Maybe 500 years you could
say that we really started colonizing
the planet you know the Portuguese the
Spaniard the British they went out there
and uh uh colonized certain lands that
they
found um and they took diseases with
them as well you know uh but the issue
is that's only happened you know the era
of colonization was maybe 500 600 years
ago that's when they started building
the ships that could go around the world
and
300 years ago we had the uh Industrial
Revolution where we went from
agriculture to manufacturing the first
few countries that started that process
and that process ended in 1980
thereabouts when uh a few count started
moving into the service region you know
they started becoming more service
oriented less manufacturing and today
we're all service economies on the
planet and uh what's uh become
much less uh part of our not only our
labor but also of our
um e economic GDP uh is uh you know
we're we're a service economy we're all
services and within Services I would say
in the last 20 years it's gotten even
worse because we used to do manual
Services you know like gardening and um
Landscaping uh barbering you know stuff
like that there uh pizza delivery you
know it kind of use your hands it's a
service where you're you're still active
physically right and that's gone right
now uh we're the only Services we're
creating our internet services and
what's internet services it's um
entertainment and ads that you can
summarize it with those two
words and a society cannot live on
entertainment and ads that's my take on
that okay too long to explain it to
those who don't have the intuition to
grasp that you cannot run a world on
entertainment and uh you know ads so uh
yeah the in fact I called it
nonwork and I give this uh scenario
where you're next to God up there in in
the sky right and you're looking at the
planet and what do you see well you see
the things that we made the ma the
physical things so you see the houses
you see the cars you see the
streets uh the food we grow you know the
uh cotton fields and uh corn fields and
so on that we can see that you can see
from up there what you can't see are the
services you know the promises the
contracts the money in the banks you
know especially the
numbers that we don't see and so so um
if if you're going to judge whether a
country is growing
economically you have to look at the
real things and not the abstract things
such as money you know you can create
all the money you
want out of the machine or just put a
number in another zero you know in the
bank account that doesn't change reality
you know you still haven't built a house
you you still don't have a car you still
don't have a street you don't have you
know the corn fields and the wheat
Fields so if you're going to judge uh
growth real growth it's got to be real
things and right now we're not growing
nowhere on the planet or we're growing
very slowly growth is really being
uh it's at a snail's pace right um the
other thing you got to keep in mind um
is uh regarding genetic diversity is
that you know we don't have new
species you know here's a a graph that
shows you know that after the dinosaurs
went away the mammals
Diversified why because the mammals go
out there and they um they squat a niche
okay they they just say oh I'm going to
eat this food and the other guy says I'm
going to eat this animal or whatever and
so what's happening is that you have all
these animals fighting for their own
interests self-interests these species
that
develop and um and they evolve and it
comes a time when all the niches are
taken over you know because immediately
every animal somewhere on the planet
makes use of the resources available to
it and so it they evolve some bigger
than the others some faster than the
others depending on you know the
conditions uh climatic conditions and
environmental conditions whatever and so
once they uh squat these niches you know
that each one takes whatever is useful
for them you know the new animals cannot
arise be or in this case mammals right
could have same thing happened to the
dinosaurs mammal like reptiles and so on
synapsids but the point here is that you
know once uh they
radiate especially at the beginning from
that you know you don't have new animals
what you have is these animals just
evolving into other species as they
travel the planet and uh uh encounter
new environments new diseases Etc and
new animals develop but uh you know you
don't have new animals and here's
another view of that one of that graph
that I just showed okay this is a
different way of seeing it here okay and
yeah what happens is you have uh
different types of animals develop okay
on the planet what happens um you cannot
have new animals and you know uh
the researchers who do experiments in
the labs you know biology and so on uh
they really don't take this into
consideration at all you know like uh if
you're going to run an experiment you're
going to try to reach some kind of
decision or figure out something in the
lab and let's say you run I don't know
fruit flies you know when did the fruit
fly start when did it start its Journey
did it start a million years ago a
100,000 years ago ago maybe only a
thousand years ago does it make any
difference well I think it does you know
it'd be nice to know you know when the
fruit fly started its Journey okay uh
and you know if you don't know that you
don't have that information you may
reach the wrong conclusions in the lab
because you don't have the full history
of this species that you're studying and
part of that issue has to do with these
uh mice you know the same fellow asked
uh the question here he says uh why
haven't big city mice gotten extinct
since Calhoun's experiments you know cun
ran experiments with mice where he put
them in a small enclosure and he allowed
them M to multiply and we had four
couples that was the founders effect the
starting point and they ended up with
2200 mice in that same enclosure and
towards the end they became homosexual
autistic and eventually The Colony
disappeared and he did this experiment I
think like 30 times or at least for 30
years since 1948 to the 1970s I think
75 and throughout the time he always got
the same result okay so he says it due
to the migration of rro mice and know
the issue is the city is a bigger place
than Calhoun's claustrophobic uh
enclosure that's one issue that's what
he was testing you know what the effect
was on the mental condition of these
animals and the city mice uh you know
they hunt they nest made they go around
and these animals um the ones that he
had coun had uh you know they were
always in the same place in the same
conditions and there's something there
that you got to keep in mind that you
know there's there's a level of you
could say
boredom that's one issue and the other
one is that they didn't have to
struggle you know they don't have to do
anything the food was there the the
water was there you know they they had
enough food and drink so they didn't
have to go out and hunt and they didn't
have that uh incentive you could say
that urge to go out there and uh do
things and so this makes you stop and
think that maybe we're in the same boat
because Cal reached the the conclusion
that humans were no different than mice
in that sense and in a way you know you
have to agree with them I mean
today we we all have the Silver Spoon
more or less you know we don't have to
struggle uh for anything you want food
you take some what is it called money
you take it to the supermarket and you
buy whatever you want and someone
brought it by Magic it came to the
shelves and you take it off the shelves
and buy it and bring it home and eat it
and if that's not good enough for you
well you get to McDonald's or Kentucky
Fried Chicken and just uh you know have
your fill and so the question here is is
we have it so easy in that sense we
don't have to
struggle and uh here we are at home you
know maybe watching TV playing games
whatever doing whatever you do
entertaining yourself because that's the
world of today a lot of
entertainment and uh what's the issue
there the issue is that you don't have
to
struggle you don't you you're not
fighting the environment the condition
you don't have to worry about lions
attacking you none of that and this more
or less the situation that the mice had
so I think you got to factor that into
uh why Calhoun's mice you know
eventually ended up being extinct and
lost their minds in fact he concluded he
says they stopped being mice and the
question is whether we stop being humans
okay and the other thing you got to
consider is the fact that when he
started his experiment
also he he took mice that were in the
labs he didn't go out into the Forest
hunting for mice or you know in the ra
at the railroad tracks or whatever he he
got them from from you know from someone
who already had mice say hey give me
four couples and so we don't know what
the origin of those mice were I mean did
he do a DNA analysis a
chromosome uh analysis of these mice of
course not and so he doesn't know what
his starting point is and again this has
to do a lot with what I was said a
minute ago that you know you got to look
at the full history of the animal that
you're going to do research on you know
when did mice
start and the way I look at this is that
you know like in the case of humans
we've been around maybe what 200 300,000
Years big window there from 200 to
300,000 what do I mean by that I mean
that if any of you today female or male
doesn't matter or in between today we
got to mention those as well you go back
in time 200 300,000 years ago and you
have sex with someone in those days you
probably would still have a viable uh
children you know uh something good
comes out that is that can continue
reproducing but the farther back you go
in time Beyond 300,000 years 400 500,000
years well at some point you're going to
reach a human that gave us origin you
know or that was in our iage with which
you cannot have viable
kids and you can say at that point
that's a different species the species
starts at reproduction and then that's
my definition of species reproduction
okay and so the question is you know uh
what is the case of the mice when can
you take one of these M lab mice take
them back in time and say this mouse can
still reproduce with this other Mouse
over there and beyond that he cannot
okay so this is the kind of question
that a lot of these um
researchers don't uh uh don't Ponder or
don't in include in their studies and
this is something you got to think
about okay uh here we have a a nice in
situation we have uh chimps use military
tactic only ever seen in humans before
and it turns out that these chimps you
know um one troop looks at the other
troop you know they're enemies they're
different countries different lands uh
sort of like you know the United States
and China something like that chimps
from different sides of the of the
Atlantic or Pacific right and says
reachers observed two Western chimpanzee
communities in Africa take to the hills
to carry out surveillance of each other
much like Recon recognizance uh missions
used by um militaries okay they then
used the Intel to the side went to enter
contested
territory okay and so um yeah they look
at each other and they say oh they do a
little study you know kind of U spying
on each
other um to see if they can have some
advantage in their Wars okay so chimps I
I guess we carry it in our Bloods we're
kind of chimps aren't we you know all of
us and here we have two chimps one is
the US the other one is the Chinese and
and uh one of the Champs the US is
quietly arming Taiwan against a Chinese
Invasion but it could backfire and
saying the Biden Administration is
treading a precarious balance between
the aggravate between not aggravating
China's nationalist president shei uh
and providing Taiwan with the weapons it
needs to potentially fend off China's
vast
military uh analyst told The Insider and
there you see the map made by the
Chinese military how they would attack
Taiwan Little Island there uh they would
attack it from the mainland let alone
you know with their own airplanes and
ships and whatever and so uh you know
you could say that maybe China is
getting
ready uh for a
war which is supposed to happen maybe in
three or four years or
thereabouts and um they want their
Province back to be part of the mainland
China and I think that's one of the
reasons she uh came to San Francisco the
other day you know and uh had a talk
with Biden I guess their main point is
you know we want our Island back we want
you guys out of here and part of the
problem is that you know uh you have
Taiwan semiconductor over there which is
the number one distributor of chips not
potato chips but uh integrated circuits
right uh in the world and it's not so
much that that's part of it part of the
equation is that the the number one
distributor but the other part is that
they have a lot of technology in their
Fabs fabrication areas and imagine if
that would fall into the hands of China
suddenly they advanc like eight or 10
years in their technology because now
they have it right there it belongs to
them so they don't have to go and steal
it through spies or whatever they they
have it there and so there's a double
whammy there you know they're they're a
little worried about China grabbing
Taiwan primarily because of that there
other things that Taiwan has and you
know the United States has reached an
agreement with China they have this one
China policy and China's the real the
communist China is the real China and
the other one's not a China it's not
part of the world it's not a country
that's officially what's out there but
then they have this fine print where it
says hey you know you can take over
Taiwan but in a peaceful manner meaning
that Taiwan has to
agree imagine if California had to agree
to be part of the Union you
know uh you know um I don't think the
United States would like it and that's
more or less the situation there and so
the question is whether there's going to
be a war in four or five years on top of
the wars we already have we have one in
Ukraine another one over there in Israel
Palestine whatever side you take there
and it's going to be quite interesting
what's going to happen next few years
okay because China is uh improving its
military capabilities on the one one
hand it's
also uh going out there and influencing
other countries um economically first
and maybe later on with military and so
you know China's growing the United
States is stalling more less you know uh
it's economic it's economy is not
growing as fast as it used to China's
growing at a faster rate right now
because it was so far behind and the
question is at some point there's going
to be a rivalry there not to mention
that we have another Empire over there
called the Russian Empire you know you
have these three Empires that run the
world and um you know so the question is
what's going to happen with all that you
got to stop and think you know I don't
think it's going to be resolved
peacefully primarily because Mother
Nature doesn't like she's not a peaceful
woman she wants War she work she works
through U conflict not through
agreements you know the the lion doesn't
reach an agreement with uh Rivals such
as the hyenas or even with its prey you
know the lion knows what it's got to do
in fact lions fight lions you know
there's no agreement between Lions you
don't reach agreement you fight you have
to kill have to murder get rid of the
other side and so um think about that
you know there's there's got to be no
peaceful solution when you have two
empires clashing in fact uh uh Alexander
destroyed the Persian Empire originally
and then the Roman Empire destroyed the
Greeks and so on and it went on and on
and on it was never peaceful okay so I
doubt very much there's going to be
peace when the interests of many people
are at
stake okay and talking about that uh
here we have good old Putin and he says
that the West is increasing risk of
weapons of mass destruction being used
so we have that added to all the rest
we've got these guys who are are um you
know playing around with fire and I mean
real fire you know and it says that uh
you know essentially that the war in
Ukraine uh they're all talking about
pressing the red buttons you know and so
the question is whether it's going to
get to that point where at some point
nobody cares or someone doesn't care on
one side one of the empires doesn't care
and it says hey I'm just going to press
the button I'm not going to lose my job
uh you know because the other side won
uh uh before I go I'm going to press the
red buttons and so you got to think
about that you know uh when you're up
there and you know especially in the
case of Putin he's being hunted he can't
travel the world because uh the courts
are going to get him you a guy like that
when you push him against the corner and
he's the boss of the Empire he's the uh
Emperor right I don't know how far you
can push him uh so I can't imagine how
Ukraine can win the war because when
it's about to win they're going to press
the red buttons and again Mother Nature
doesn't work through peace she works
through War okay she's a nasty old witch
you can change that letter first letter
if you want and here you see also what's
happening to the US economy why uh Putin
is saying yeah the United States is in
trouble um these These are polls that
they had out there and they're saying
you know the United States is is running
into some kind of pro trouble you have
recession fears inflation fears and then
uh job market booming well a lot of
people think that um there are problems
with the uh job market and then also the
US economy leads the world but you know
compared with other developed Nation the
United States is not doing so great you
know and so uh at least this is the
sense uh that people have you know
people who uh participate in the polls
but it gives you an idea uh in a way if
people are suffering if people are
feeling the impact of what's going on in
the global economy because if everybody
is you know in great shape you know the
numbers would be in Reverse you would
see more people saying no everything's
peachy and I don't care what's going on
out there I'm doing fine you know so
people would in general vote in favor
and say no we're doing fine but when
people say we're not doing fine it's
because they're feeling the impact of
what's happening out there okay and so
you got to look at the polls because
it's a way of uh getting a you know a
feel for uh whether what's happening in
the economy is affecting them okay and
uh uh you know the United States is now
stalling a little bit its economy is
stalling and it's growing at a very
uh slow rate and here's part of the
reason okay here's the world world
population okay you can see how it's
grown over time I think this starts at
the beginning of the Christian
era uh see I think so yeah thereabouts
okay so it starts at the Christian era
and you can see how we progressed over
time and what you're seeing there is not
only population which is what that graph
shows but population implies you know
construction what have you constructed
in throughout this time okay and um you
know again if you're out there in um in
outer space and you look at this you
would see you know and you were there
also eternally for the last 2,000 years
you would see how the world expanded as
far as its economics in other words what
we constructed real stuff you know and
you say okay we were here very little we
had these TPS and Tents and from there
we built houses and now we build these
Big Sky scrapers you would see you know
the world
growing and the question is you know is
there any more room for
growth there's room as far as space is
concerned you know how much room we have
that that we have but what we don't have
is the um stimulus and you keep growing
the stimulus ver involves more
population which is not happening
worldwide and the second one is that we
should be constructing you know doing uh
more manufacturing and uh work that uh
builds
infrastructure and that's not the big
part of the economy anymore okay uh what
you see growing now is again a lot of uh
abstraction internet services and you
cannot have those growing and say oh we'
created
jobs yeah you created jobs but they're
fake jobs I say that Services is not a
job services means you're unemployed if
you're doing Services okay that's the
way I look at it because you're not
creating anything and um you know in the
end it trickles down it does trigger or
or
stimulate manufacturing and agriculture
but not to the degree it used to see
when population was growing
exponentially there was exponential
growth of both agriculture you needed
more food for more people and
Manufacturing but when uh Services
overtook Manufacturing you know now
you're creating jobs in an abstraction
that is not real growth it's fake growth
and so when they say I'm working in
Services well you're an unemployed
you're a
bum okay one fell says changing subject
a little bit here you should look into
the Jews as neanderthals Theory actually
quite convincing uhhuh well I did um a
video on
Jewish neanderthals you can look it up
okay and one of the Fells who vouched
for that theory was this fell his name
is Stan G and he develops his hybrid
origin Theory crom Magnum uh man evolves
in Northern India the anal man inv
evolved in Europe and the Middle East
35,000 years ago Chom magnan abandons
India and heads West uh through the
Middle East into Europe overrunning uh
by 25,000 years ago the predominant type
in Europe is chromagnon in the Middle
East a hybrid population emerges that's
in general his theory a summary of his
theory of the swow and so while they
were in the Middle East he's talking
about a hybrid population
emerges okay well I have a different
take on this whole thing and I did cover
it in my
nandal
um uh video and
here it is one I think one picture is
worth a thousand words here it is uh
Neanderthal was a uh an Arctic species
he was a hairy monkey as far as I'm
concerned okay he he didn't look
anything like us or in other words he
was a two-footer okay instead of a
four-footer but I'm saying in general
terms I think he was quite different you
can tell the difference between a nandal
skeleton and a human skeleton and I'm
not an expert all I can tell you I I
look and I can see the differences okay
and I think anyone who looks at human
skeleton and nandal skeleton can tell
the difference now nandal grew in Europe
like this fellow says and I have a hard
time believing that he would go to Sunny
Israel or Iraq or Syria right to hunt
what to hunt camels I mean you know he
was hunting mammoths and uh woly rhinos
and other animals of that
were popular in the north I don't think
the nandal ever migrated Beyond uh
Europe okay so the Neanderthals that uh
they say are Jewish neanderthals the in
you know in regions that today form part
of
Israel um I don't think they were
nandal okay and you say well what do you
know well I don't know anything don't
worry about me I'm just say that there's
a couple papers at least that I have out
there of people from Israel who studied
them studied these uh Neanderthal
alleged quotations on that Neanderthal
Bones from the caves in Israel and Iraq
and they came to the conclusion that
they're not your classical neanderthals
meaning the bones there the skeletons
the uh you know the the especially the
heads uh don't match quite readily the
um the nandal that you find in Spain and
France and
Germany they're different they're
noticeably different they measured many
aspects of their bones and so on they
said these are not nandal and so it's
not me saying that there it's people out
there in um in Israel who studied these
bones and all I can say is look up uh
papers that talk about the so-called
Jewish neanderthals in other words
so-called neanderthals that were found
in caves in Israel and Iraq primarily
and you'll find that there they haven't
reached an agreement but I think uh all
of them agree that there are differences
they you know the experts who look at
these bones they see differences between
the bones in Europe and in Israel right
now are they a different species well
that's for you to reach your own
conclusion I say they're not okay so no
there was no uh breeding in inbreeding
or interbreeding between yandal and
humans as far as I'm concerned they were
two different
species um if aandal found a human he
would have killed him and eat eaten him
and vice versa I don't think uh you know
they would have sh shook hands and drank
beer together and swapped wives I don't
think that happened okay and um here's
um something to to top that one on a new
Theory how nandal uh DNA spread in Asia
and researchers have discovered that
nandal interbred with the ancestors of
Asians at two points in history giving
this population an extra infusion of
nandal DNA European uh yeah DNA what's
the issue here the issue is that uh we
had this fellow his name is swante Pabo
and he's part of the um max plank
Institute he did a study from I think
2007 to 2010 where he issued his report
together with his group and they came to
conclusion that um
neanderthals uh that that we have nandal
DNA but it's uh it's not as clear-cut as
you would think uh the way he the way
they presented their report is that you
have
non-africans have more Neanderthal DNA
than Africans that's the way they
presented their report they lied they
lied because they omitted a very
important point or they they put it
really in a very fine print which was
never dealt with ever again and that is
that American Indians and Papua
ninians have more Neanderthal DNA than
Europeans and you would say well how is
that possible I mean if if uh
neanderthals uh were in Europe and they
made it with humans in Europe with the
crow magnets right why is it that these
far away places American Indians Papa
ninians have more Neanderthal DNA than
Europeans but they don't put it that way
they the way they presented or the what
they emphasize is that non-africans have
more than Africans so they lied by doing
that and they never dealt with that
subject ever
again okay uh one F
says says does money
exist you said that when money is No
More Humans will become extinct so you
also say that existence equal location
plus shape uhhuh uh not true what I say
something a little different okay and
here it is say exist is object plus
location not location plus shape shape
is uh a um an adjective okay and we're
saying that it's got to be the word
object you can't change the words on
that definition that's the first uh
thing I need to point out and so so does
money and or trade exist it was an
invention of civilization if money had a
standard and was backed by gold and
silver then it would exist what's your
take on this and here's the take on this
okay uh shape is an adjective okay and
it is irrational to say that a concept
exists okay so what we have is money is
a static concept okay um and you know
you just it's you give value to this
thing we call money and it's only be
it's in your mind it's not out there
it's it's in your head right and trade
is a dynamic concept trade means you're
going to exchange something okay and so
gold you know the rock uh that's a
that's an object that's a thing okay let
me put this over
here that's a thing okay and uh oh
give me a second
here and uh paper money is also a thing
so you can say that gold the The Rock
right the metal right that exists uh but
you can't say money exists because money
is a concept that you have in your brain
okay so you can't say that money
exists uh so you have to be careful to
distinguish the op from the concept gold
exists the paper money that exists the
paper exists with the ink on it right
that you can say exists but you can't
say money exists or trade exists because
those are Concepts one is a static
concept the other one a dynamic concept
okay uh we had a visit from the aliens
and here they are two aliens they found
in Peru they say that they only have
three fingers and etc etc etc okay I
don't know what these uh two mummies are
okay but I can tell you one thing for
sure 100% sure they don't come from
another planet okay it's impossible for
life to travel Interstellar I'm on
record with that okay you can look up
the Pioneer anomaly video that I made
and get acquainted with the theory but
it's impossible to travel Interstellar
we have no chance of ever going to the
nearest star we can only look at it from
you know the telescope from afar but um
we cannot travel Interstellar and uh so
no life no living entity can travel
Interstellar that's the position we take
here there's a theory behind that I'm
not going to go over that right now you
can ask the question someday okay uh so
all I'm saying is you can't trouble
Interstellar whatever those two mummies
are they don't come from outside the
Earth whatever it is it came from within
the Earth it could be a hoax could be
for real who knows maybe they Cho two
fingers off for all I know I mean I
don't know uh but they don't come from
abroad meaning you know from another
planet from the land of the
Klingons and final issue here is autism
okay and again uh this has to do a
little bit with the uh coun experiment
okay uh F says diet is a more powerful
than most people
think um
and so F goes out there saying you know
that autism might be caused by some
environmental or
dietary uh those would be the causes
okay that's the source and uh I think
it's the same fellow he continues he
says um maybe it's not but I don't know
I don't remember now autism I think it's
a combination of D dis genics and
vestigiality and he goes on defining
both of those so if you turn off certain
genes in a chicken embryo you can get
them to grow dinosaur like faces why
does he say that well he says that
because the theory right now is that um
dinosaurs or that uh you know the came
from some kind of uh feathered animal in
the past uh they found one here in
Germany which I went to see by the way
um and that's that dinosaurs were more
like chickens and I have no problem with
that except that you know we have to be
careful with extrapolating saying oh the
dinosaurs are still alive because uh all
these birds you know they're dinosaurs
you know that's a long stretch okay so
the fact that dinosaurs could have had
had feathers does not mean that uh a
chickens are dinosaurs okay which is
more or less what these people conclude
and they just state that like if it was
a a fact uh instead of you know pulling
back and being a little bit skeptical
about that theory okay anyways um we
Define um autism and here we have it
autism the psychology of Hunter gathers
this this fell defines it as such and uh
he continues saying that you know um
this is uh vestage from the old days
that we've got some of these genes
inside of us and they pop up in this day
and age okay so that the reason we have
autism today is that it just uh in our
genes and they just popped up again okay
after many
generations and you know he says the
reason we know that the autism is
vestigial is because the brains of um uh
alistic people are smaller and have
fewer nerve connections just like all
domesticated animals and it is the
reason why the average person comes
across this thoughtless
livestock why does he say that because
he says that he's autistic but he's uh
very intelligent he's saying that he's
intelligent okay so he's trying to
justify why he's an autist and so
intelligent and he says because the
average person is not to some degree uh
I would agree with him saying that you
know the average person is not very
intelligent you know or maybe they don't
investigate things which is maybe not
different a little different ins Saye
intelligent but you know but no I I'm
saying that I don't think it has
anything to do with vestigial anything
it's not uh autism that it has very
little to do with what happened in the
past I'm saying uh that we are becoming
more
autistic uh because of what Calhoun
showed in the lab in other words that if
you have inbreeding several Generations
at some point uh you're going to have
problems mental problems if especially
in a crowded environment and that's what
we have today we have humans living in
cities which are very crowded right uh
we have these enormous ant holes we're
not creating new
cities there's ample room I mean all of
Russia biggest country in the world 1/8
of the I think of the surface of the
Earth completely
empty uh and the Russians are now in uh
population decline especially after of
the war with Ukraine and why is that
well because you know people live in
cities and in cities you don't have kids
and nobody's moving out of the city to
create new cities in the middle of
nowhere why because you know everybody
does exactly the opposite they go from
the villages to the big cities to get
jobs primarily in the service industry
and so all this land is is just going to
when when we all die when humans
disappear from the face of the Earth
we're going to find you know the
Martians came here a million years later
they would find that all this land was
not occupied they had all this land
nobody lived in it and all the people
were crowded in these cities why why
didn't they go out there and populate
you know all this vast land that was
empty out there well because the era of
colonization is over okay we don't we
don't colonize anymore we don't spread
out and colonize the land anymore we're
not going to be founding new cities
and so yeah this is how humans are going
to end and just as uh icing on the cay I
just want to clarify that autism there's
short range overc connectivity and long
range under connectivity in other words
different sides of the brains are not
connected in an autistic person so it's
not that they have more connections or
fewer connections is that they have the
wrong quotations on that connections
parts of the brains are not connect
connected as well as in a normal human
being so if you're autistic it's not
because you're so intelligent it's
because you don't have your brain
connected you know and uh so for tasks
that require us to combine or assimilate
information in different parts of the
brain like social function and Complex
Motor test individuals with autism have
more trouble okay uh that's more or less
the conclusion of the doctors of the
researchers you can take it you know
with a grain of salt if you want and
then uh just in case um here's the the
case for Down syndrome individuals with
Down Syndrome suffer from developmental
delay intellectual disability and an
early onset of neurod degeneration
Alzheimer's like disease or precocious
dementia due to what an extra chromosome
21 what does this mean it means that you
know uh when when you say uh oh this
person suffers from Down syndrome people
say well yeah he was born that way well
when you say this person is autistic a
lot of people say well it's what he ate
it's the environment it's all this
poison that all the companies are
putting in our foods and who knows what
it's the air we breathe the pollution
so you don't say that for a Down
syndrome because that's so
self-evident and the only thing there a
person might say you know who believes
that it's all uh environmental and food
they would say well it's their parents
who ate the wrong stuff and that's why
the kid came out like that well I'm not
sure if eating you know is going to
change your chromosones
uh even for your children I think
something else is going on and again I
stick by my words that this has to do
with inbreeding after thousands of years
and now we're suffering the consequences
of that on the one hand it was good
because you know our forefathers our
great grandfathers especially they went
through this sifting process where they
were encountered
diseases diseases killed those that had
no natural defenses and those who went
ahead they had children and those are
our uh
forefathers and that's why you know if
you look at today Japanese a Russian uh
someone from Africa or South America or
Europe were all
clones of each other and you say well
why is that well it's because our
forefathers whether in Japan in Africa
Europe and South America they went
through the same sifting process those
who made it across you know they all had
similar DNA chromosomes and so on and uh
those who died did not have the natural
defenses to overcome some of these
diseases that's why we're all the same
today and it doesn't matter if you're
Japanese or Indian or whatever we we're
all clones because we went through the
same sifting process thanks to our
forefathers and that's good as far as
you know your health the fact that we
don't die of diseases these days in this
day and age especially childhood
diseases you know the whooping cough and
so on we don't die of those things
anymore we die of old age today but at
the same time we are all clones of each
other and now we're having genetic
diseases or ailments or problems right
disorders why because we've been in
breeding for so long that now we don't
have to worry about contagious diseases
we have to worry about genetic
diseases that's my take on
that okay let's move on to the subject
matter of today I'm going to start with
uh some questions and comments that
people made uh because it leads us into
the subject matter which is Mr Fineman
Dr Richard finan Dick Dicky finan okay
and so let's start with this follow says
physical uh he says relating to the body
where did he get it from he got it from
he just copied and pasted from the
Oxford dictionary says relating to the
body as opposed to the mind and it also
says relating to things perceived
through the senses as opposed to the
mind you know talking about touch and
see and touch famous C touch they say uh
mathematicians think that anything that
you can see in or touch and or touch uh
is what object is what physical means
and that's not
true okay that's an irrational
definition because if you can't see or
touch it is it physical for example you
know the table the Klingon has on the
other side of the universe which you
cannot see or touch is that
physical he say well he can see and
touch it or or I can see and touch it if
I travel over there well that's not fair
because you're saying that until you do
until you run the experiment of seeing
and touching it's not physical so you're
going to wait for an experiment until
then it's not a table is not physical
see the problem okay so but uh here's
here's this Fell's contradiction he says
physical presences are forms okay an
object is a form which has physical
presence and then he tops it off says
there are physical presences other than
objects see when all around in circles
okay yeah I'd like for you to mention
which physical
presence uh which is not an object okay
uh we'd like to know okay what the
fellow just states that he's saying you
know uh an object is is that which has
form which has physical presence but
there are physical presen say which not
which do not include objects I don't
know he's talking about ghosts or
Spirits I have no idea which again uh if
it's physical and you're talking about
SE touch right because that's what it is
well I don't know he's got to explain
that okay another fellow questions the
ropes especially in regards to gravity
and he says I don't know if your
hypothesis asserts objects closer to
each other have more connecting ropes
okay if so what mechanism adds or
removes connective
ropes and the mechanism is known as
distance and I don't mean the distance
of mathematics I mean which is distance
traveled I'm talking about separation
qualitative Separation The Closer two
objects are to each other since every
Atom from one object is connected to
every atom of the other object through
these ropes the closer they get together
the ropes fan out so you're not creating
new robes you're not saying oh more
robes entered from you know outer space
or whatever no what you're saying is the
objects are already connected and as
they get closer to each other you can
see what's happening there the ropes fan
out and it's that gradual FL Fanning out
which is the acceleration of gravity the
closer they are the more the rose fan
out the faster you go because of more
more and more Rose fan out that's the
mechanism we propose for Gravity that is
the acceleration of gravity or the
mechanism of the acceleration of
gravity uh here's uh the single thread
okay ah
see if I can get it
here no I don't have it okay anyways we
have a single thread let me put this
other one
here see if this one is
okay I didn't check these
out no uh I don't have either one but
anyways uh what I want to say is that
you have the single thread that's that's
our hypothesis that's our assumption
that there's a single thread throughout
the Universe This Thread weaves every
atom and every rope that connects any
two atoms so there's only a single
thread if we would take every atom and
disassemble it and disassemble every
rope we would end up with a single
thread in the entire universe a single
closed loop thread okay and the single
closed loop thread you know when you
weave it you weave the atoms and the
ropes setting to connect them and so uh
there are no more ropes
that come out of nowhere and you know
come in between two objects that's
that's not the theory the theory is that
as two objects approach each other the
atoms that in uh are connected by these
ropes the number of ropes that connect
these two um objects is is a fixed
amount because it's from one atom to
another and we're talking about hydrogen
atoms and we don't care if it's uranium
92 uh protons and electrons right 92
hydrogen atoms and what 205 or 208 um
neutrons okay uh we're we're talking
about you know them coming together and
um and the ROP fan out so we're not
creating new ropes okay I just want to
clarify that for those of you who are
not familiar with the theory okay and
here we have another fell he says how do
we tell the difference between the blue
stuff and the black stuff if it is both
invisible and intangible and this
proposed that uh the thread you know the
Rope model uh that's an ether and I'm
saying no it's not an ether because
ether is a bunch of particles and so I
said you know um for I put the challenge
out there for anyone who uh can come up
and tell me what The Ether looks like
and he said well you're your ropes are
an ether I said oh oh is that's true and
he drew it and this is what he
Illustrated
and the problem here is that we have
three things we have the black stuff we
have the round white stuff there the uh
supposedly the atoms I guess and we have
the uh blue connections which apparently
are the ropes okay and so he said how do
we tell the difference between any of
these if we can't see them and the issue
is it's not a question of seeing we the
first thing we do in science is what
they do in in the mafia we wipe out the
witness we kill the Observer there are
no observers in science in in rational
science uh observers exist only in
mathematical physics in the religion of
mathematical physics and so we have no
observers here you have to tell the
crowd what you mean by Ether and the guy
says Phantom thread ether I don't know
which one of those is the ether is it
the white stuff the black stuff or the
blue stuff and he said well I can't see
them well you have to make them visible
in fact you did make them visible and so
you have to tell me which of those
three things is The Ether right now you
can't say all three of them are The
Ether okay because ether can only be one
object if if you're going to treat as an
object if you're going to say that the
thread is an object okay and you know
when I show the thread I show a single
closed loop thread in fact um this what
it looks like here it is that's what I'm
saying it's a single object now this
object you know as it twins around turns
into ropes and into atoms okay but uh
here this this was showing something
different in fact he shows that the blue
stuff is separate something different
than the white stuff because the blue
stuff is all
connected together but uh it doesn't
blend like in my U hypothesis it doesn't
blend with the white stuff otherwise he
would have painted in white and if we
paint the black stuff white as well then
we have
nothing
so uh the ball is still in his court
he's got to tell us what he means by
Ether okay and if it's an object you
know we don't want you to Define it we
want you to point to it and name it
illustrate it anywhere on the
internet okay uh here we have um another
fell says this theory is the best
description of gravity yet with numerous
evidence across all Fields evidence uhuh
you should be less skeptical about it
even though this thought experiment
might seem counter
okay also give Brian green or brain
green I guess a chance to explain the
Troubles of the Newtonian alternative
what is this fell talking about well
he's talking about Good Old brain green
okay green brain and uh he just pointed
out to this U the one episode of The
Elegant Universe which was I guess uh
the biggest show that Brian Green made
or at least one of them and uh in there
he says strength Theory says that we may
be living in a universe where reality
meets science fiction oh my God that's a
bad way to start a a you know a a
scientific uh Theory right or
explanation says a universe of 11
Dimensions 11 Dimensions I mean I I
don't know how much beer this guy drank
but you can see him drinking there right
uh with parallel universes right next
door okay and so they have all these
parallel universes you can see all the
magic stuff he put out there he's saying
this is physics or science or whatever
strength theory is surprisingly simple
okay it says that everything in the
universe from the tiniest particle to
the most distant star is made from one
kind of ingredient unimaginably small
vibrating strands of what
energy vibrating strands of energy which
he calls
strings okay well what can I say you
know there's no thing as energy if we
knew what it was and we're going to be
discussing that with good old dick finan
today but um question is you know this
guy's talking about many dimensions he's
saying that it's uh very simple to
understand is it uhuh and he shows us
magic tricks
unexplained magic tricks he just says we
don't know the cause we don't know the
theory we don't know the explanations
physical interpretations we don't know
the mechanisms but it is
so okay so no not much uh to learn from
good old uh Brian
Green another fellow more or less the
same thing he points to a Dr K says
here's Professor Alex
karage okay I'll call him Dr K who goes
against definitions themselves in maths
I thought it might interest you for one
of your various points okay and and this
what the good old um Dr K has to to say
he says it on the um ver
acetum program or series of Derek Miller
and they're referring to UK's definition
of geometric figures you know point line
and plane and good old Alex K this
professor he says Don't Give me a
definition that's going to have an
infinite recursion okay so he doesn't
want to saying uh defining and then
saying and this definition of this word
is this and then goes and tries to
Define every word of that definition as
well so he doesn't want a infinite
recursion and ver him ask are the
definitions a bad idea uhuh and so what
does k say he says you shouldn't have
definitions you should have undefined
terms now this is a professor okay who's
saying this he says you got to have
undefined terms in fact to this day um
point line and plane you know they um
there they remain as undefined terms ter
you know in you know these n um they
remain undefined they have no way of
defining them uh admittedly okay so all
these people who teach geometry say
these are undefined terms he says I'm
not going to tell you what a point is
I'm not going to tell you what a line is
I'm not going to tell you what a plane
is all I'm going to tell you is that is
what the postulates are that they're
assumed to satisfy it's the
relationships between the objects that's
important not the definitions of the
object object themselves well poor old
Dr K did not realize that you know um
you don't Define objects okay you point
to them and uh and so you you define
Concepts and point line and plane what
are they they they're called what
geometric figures right so if it's a
geometric figures you're not going to
Define it you're going to point to it
and there just so I educate Dr K or
professor K there um not be with korin
who was Dr Death right also Dr K but
Professor K should learn that you know
there there you have the pictures you
have a point you have a line and a plane
what is a point well you can see
objectively what's coming out of the
screen into your eyes now maybe you're
blind you know maybe you uh shot up
today and you can't see very well or
think very well but I'm telling you
what's coming out of the screen is
objective for everybody on planet Earth
okay whatever you interpret is a
subjective but what's coming out of the
screen is a uh for the word point is a
2d dot that's what's coming out of the
screen what's coming out of the screen
for line is a 2d elongated rectangle and
what's coming out of the pl uh screen
for the word plane is a 2d Square okay
so they're all 2D they're all
two-dimensional these objects in fact
there's no object that is neither 2D or
3D all objects are 2D or 3D there's no
object that is 1D or z d or 4D and above
okay and so uh why do they say that the
point is zero D why do they say that a
line is 1 D well because they're
referring to location and itinerary
respectively okay so uh they say well
location well why did you put a dot why
are you pictorially representing the
word location with a DOT and calling the
whole shebang a point while are you
representing an itinerary with a line
and it could be a dotted line because
that's the way they usually put it
because each dot is a location right
meaning they're talking about an
itinerary and they're saying that's 1 D
well you know an itinerary is not any D
at
all and a location is not any D at all
either they're not Zero D and 1D and
itinerary has nothing to do do with
Dimensions because it's not a physical
object so you either talk about the
figure the geometric figure or you're
going to be talking about you know
Concepts Dynamic concept like itinerary
or static concept like location okay and
here uh just to rub it in a little bit
you know is it is this what we're going
to do here uh we're going to uh
represent love with a heart is a heart
Zero D Zero Dimensional uh we're going
to represent intelligence uh with a
brain is a brain one-dimensional are we
going to say that Grace is represented
by God you know a three-dimensional
being is that what uh we represents
concepts with pictorially represent them
with so again you know you cannot you
cannot represent concept with objects
that's okay if you want to do a little
poetry little art no problem but don't
bring it into science don't bring it
into physics and tell me that a heart
represents love or that a Point
represents
location okay and this is where the
problem is that's why they say we can't
Define it of course you can't Define it
because you're confusing concepts with
objects you're trying to represent a
concept such as location with a DOT and
you're calling the whole thing a point
and think you can get away with that not
in physics point is 2D or 3D you can
have a ball representing no problem but
you cannot say that that represents
location location has no victorial
representation okay and the final issue
here little article that came out I
thought I'd rub it in there it says see
the first astounding images from the ukl
Dark Matter
telescope Dark Matter telescope what the
hell is that I thought Dark Matter was
invisible and intangible and these
people have a telescope the uclid
telescope to what to see dark matter I
guess that's what telescopes are used
for and yeah the issue is here is that
um these people don't look at dark
matter they're looking at the same thing
for which they don't need a to see any
more than than what we see out there
with a common eye and that's you see the
visible stuff so with a telescope okay
so you can see farther out in space
meaning you can see maybe the galaxies
and even some of the stars of the
galaxies you can see the visible stuff
you're never going to see dark matter
because by definition dark matter is
invisible intangible right also uh and
uh and so you know you you need no
telescope for that what you need is to
make a proposal what you think dark
matter is and make it visible to the
eyes you know just make a hypothesis an
assumption supposition and say look this
is what I think M dark matter is and you
can represent it with particles as they
do no problem but then you have
particles and you don't need a telescope
for that you just need to make an
assumption on what you think dark matter
is okay and so you can say oh dark
matter is a bunch of particles and they
weigh a lot and they're small and
whatever you can describe that and then
and then once you do that you got to
explain how those particles create the
effects such as the Galaxy rotation
problem which is uh means that they're
sprinkled on the outside of a galaxy
only preferentially for some reason I
don't know why you got to tell me and
they're sprinkled outside the Galaxy you
know it just uh encapsulates the Galaxy
because otherwise you know you cannot
explain or mathematicians cannot explain
why the stars on the outside travel
faster than those on the inside or at
the same speed or faster you know uh
Pluto doesn't travel faster than Mercury
around the sun it's the other way around
and in the case of stars it it is that
Pluto would be traveling faster than
Mercury around the Sun and you say well
how can that be well we can explain it
we put more mass more matter outside of
Pluto and that would explain why Pluto
can go faster than
Mercury okay and uh so they say uh that
that's what's happening to a Galaxy so
they sprinkle this stuff in there and
they say there's all this matter which
we cannot
see and which is translucent transparent
invisible whatever because you can see
the stars in the background right
through this dark matter thingy and so
even if you put dots in there and say
okay here we have all this matter it
weighs a lot no problem but then the
question
is how with that do you produce you know
the Galaxy rotation problem meaning that
stars on the outside travel faster than
those on the inside you still have to
answer that question the the mechanism
and even particles you cannot explain
because in order to explain it you would
have to show how this particle
is in physical contact with a
star connection you know physical
connection of some kind the ropes yeah
no there is no such thing as dark matter
because you don't need Dark Matter to
explain the Galaxy rotation problem this
is very
simple and the first thing you got to
explain why don't why don't the stars on
the outside right especially those on
the outside but all of them for that
matter especially those on the outside
when the Galaxy rotates why don't they
go flying out you know out of the Galaxy
that's all you got to explain and the
only way you can explain it the only way
you can rationally explain it is if that
star somehow is connected to the center
of the Galaxy meaning to all other stars
in the galaxy only then you can explain
why the whole thing rotates like a uh um
single platform you know you're on the
on the uh carousel on the merry go round
and you know the whole thing travels at
the same speed uh same time you know
those the horsey on the inside and the
buggy on the outside they they travel at
the same rate because the whole platform
is turning at the same time why because
they're all connected they're all on the
same platform and that's the case with
uh Galaxy it
rotates you know the ones on the outside
almost practically at the same speed as
those on the inside or faster meaning
they travel at the same rate around why
because uh they're all connected then
you can explain it but if they're not
connected the first thing you had to
explain is why doesn't this star just go
flying out of the uh uh Galaxy and it's
very simple so connection explains it
all and to top it off same uh
publication right so dark matter may
have come from a second darker big bang
you know these people people are so
clueless they don't know what to invent
anymore you know they they have to
invent a second big bang and uh to try
to cover all the holes in their theories
so you know you wonder about these
mathematicians it's like they have
nothing else to do then uh come up with
all this nonsense to try to cover the
holes in their theor so they create Dark
Matter Dark Energy Big Bang um big bang
one but uh black holes and worm holes
and so on they have to create these non-
entities all these Spirits in fact
Spirits probably easier to imagine than
uh Concepts such as uh you know dark
matter and dark energy um to cover their
holes that's the only reason these
things were ever created and the problem
here this is this is what should shock
you is that you have all these
mathematicians on planet Earth almost in
every University Research Center
professionals Etc and you're studying
what black holes and dark matter and
dark energy that's where your uh funds
are going in directly or indirectly
that's where your funds are going into
the study of inexistent stuff they're
studying souls and spirits and
conscience uh you know Souls going to
heaven that kind of stuff it's even
worse because again they're only dealing
with abstract concept mathematical
Concepts and so think about that next
time you pay your taxes coming
up okay so how does this lead to Mr
Fineman well because he was a supporter
all this stuff and um Richard finan you
know he um was a very popular teacher
okay very popular teacher because he was
charismatic he told jokes and so on and
here you have uh just an image you know
so that you can see why he was kind of
popular with the students uh he would
tell jokes and uh talk in a friendly and
also in a straightforward manner about
stuff and people like that because they
say oh I can finally understand this
teacher instead of some of these other
professors or instructors who went off
into math and stuff like that this fell
just tells it straight out like the way
it is okay that's why he became so
popular okay and uh good old dick here
he uh won a Nobel Prize okay here um
here he is uh he won a third of a Nobel
Prize right for developing Quantum
electrodynamics otherwise known as QED
what was his contribution well um
primarily this SpaceTime diagram okay he
says you got two electrons and they send
one of these virtual photons virtual
Quantum whatever and they interact and
that pushes the two electrons away okay
and so um this is it this is primarily
what he contributed he got a noble for
this onethird of a noble okay uh they
gave him a quarter of the what a third
of a
coin okay fine so this is his
contribution uh so how much did he know
about QED I mean this was his down down
his aisle you know this is this is what
he worked on this is what he studied
this is what he contributed to Quantum
Mechanics science if you can call it
science physics and he says will you
understand what I'm going to tell you
you think I'm going to uh explain it to
you so you can understand it no you're
not going to be able to understand it
you see my physics students don't
understand it either that is because I
don't understand it nobody does while I
am describing to you how nature works
you won't understand why nature works
the way that way in other words he had
no physical interpretation which is what
physics is all about which is what you
know we wanted to always know or
understand understand right but you see
nobody understands that I can't explain
why nature behaves in this peculiar way
the theory of quantum electrodynamics
describes not explains but describes
nature as absurd from the point of view
of Common Sense meaning he cannot
explain it me
mechanistically why because he's talking
about particles that's why you cannot
explain with particles discrete
particles How the Universe works and it
agrees fully with experiment which we
don't care anything about so I hope you
can accept nature as she is absurd no we
cannot uh we can accept that you're
ignorant that would have uh long gone a
long ways to helping people understand
that the mathematicians don't know squat
that would have been great if he would
have said look we're we're all so
ignorant he said it in in softer terms
but I would be a little more uh adamant
because today people say oh we know it
all and you say what do you know can you
explain gravity oh uh you're you're
talking about a physical interpretation
that's philosophy and they brush it
aside and they say let me tell you about
my equations the problem with equations
that's a description as good old Dicky
just said okay but the problem is that
you know uh that's not science that's
like saying you measured the table and
you measured it to be one meter and the
other guy comes over said no no I got a
better measurement I got one meter and
one micrometer so I'm a little more
accurate than you okay so you measure a
table is that science yeah measurement
and followed by an equation or is it
explaining something like gravity why
you know my famous trick here why the
pencil Falls downwards not to the
ceiling that's what you got to explain
and the only way to explain that is by
making visible the invisible you have to
show me what is in contact with a
pencil and if you say well
nothing why nothing because you know I
can't see anything above or below so
there's nothing there well because you
you're talking about seeing and touching
and that's not what a thing is a thing
is that which has shape so you got to
draw the shape that you think is
connecting the uh uh pencil or coming in
contact with pencil because you know
maybe something's pushing from above
something's uh pulling From Below
whichever I don't care but you got to
show me what's in contact with a pencil
and for that you have to make the
invisible stuff the mediators visible so
that I can understand your mechanism
that's what it's all about and they've
never done that because they say oh an
object's that which I can see and touch
and I can't see and touch anything there
above or below so there's nothing there
but if you say that there's nothing
there if you're talking about
action at a distance you're talking
about black magic you're talking about
witchcraft that's the problem okay that
means you're going to invoke black magic
and say it's done by Magic Mother Nature
works by Magic and that's why these
people like uh Richard fan concluded
that QED or Quantum in general um cannot
be explained nobody understands it and
just in case uh let's make sure that
that's the case he say quantum mechanics
is the description of the behavior of
matter and light in all its details and
in particular of the happenings on an
atomic scale things on a very small
scale behave like nothing that you have
any direct experience about they do not
behave like waves they do not behave
like particles they do not behave like
clouds or Billard balls or weights or on
Springs or like anything that you have
ever seen uhuh we choose and then he
talks about you know why they included
with this he talks about the um slit
experiment he says we choose to examine
a phenomenon which is impossible
absolutely impossible to explain in any
classical way and which has in it the
heart of quantum mechanics in reality it
contains the only mystery we cannot make
the mystery go away by explaining how it
works we will just tell you how it works
in other words he's going to describe
right one might like might still like to
say how does it work what is the
Machinery behind the law no one has
found any Machinery be behind the law no
one can explain any more than we have
just explained no one will give you any
deeper representation of the situation
we have no ideas about a more basic
mechanism from which these results can
be
deduced and uh yeah the whole problem uh
is is really comes down to the fact that
like he said like cannot be a particle
and light cannot be a wave it's
neither and they insist on doing it with
particles and with
waves when uh when he's telling you it
ain't one or the other so we got a
contradiction instead of going to to the
U basement dark basement and you know
thinking hard and uh uh you know
proposing assumptions you know
brainstorming
assumptions the guy says it just ain't
particles and it ain't
waves okay so what is it it says nothing
like you ever imagin well have have they
tried this you know a rope this you can
imagine in fact I'm showing it to you
right now and a rope is neither a wave
nor a particle and now we have a
different uh proposal here a different
Universe right okay so uh he continues
saying
um the quantum mechanic Behavior things
is is quite strange yeah because they're
trying to do it with particles in fact
which are not particles anyways because
the so-called particles of quantum
mechanics are really numbers they're
Concepts and they're trying to move
Concepts so when they tell you that they
have a particle accelerator at CERN or
at slack or FY lab or whatever uh
they're not talking about particles what
they're accelerating is numbers what
they're doing is they're saying
something accelerated and we're going to
call it a particle and we're going to
represent it with a number because we're
interested in Def in determining what
the energy was and what the mass is what
the charge is they're going to go into
numbers and units they're not going to
be talking about a ball okay and that's
important that you know or that you
understand that nobody has an everyday
experience to lean on to get a rough
intuitive idea of what will happen we
could either describe what can happen in
a rather rough physical way meaning they
can't describe it at all right telling
you more or less what happens without
giving you the precise laws meaning they
cannot tell you anything about what
they're what's in that invisible World
laws of everything or we could on the
other hand give the precise laws in
their abstract form but then because of
the abstractions you wouldn't know what
they were all about physically yeah
that's the point they're not doing
physics that's the problem with these
people they're not doing physics quantum
mechanics is not physics it's just a
bunch of abstractions uh mathematical
abstraction that's all it is the latter
meth method is unsatisfactory because it
is completely abstract yeah tell me
about it and the first uh way leaves an
uncomfortable feeling because no one uh
no because one doesn't know exactly what
is true and what is false yeah in
science we don't care what is true or
false we care about explanations
mechanisms okay we are not sure how to
overcome this difficulty okay and then
uh what is this conclusion
okay here let me remove
this he says the following he says I
think I can safely say that nobody
understands
Quantum do not keep asking yourself if
you can possibly avoid it but how can it
be like that nobody knows how it can be
like that the more you see how strangely
nature behaves the harder it is to make
a model that explains how even the the
simplest phenomena actually worked so
theoretical physics has given up on
that they've given up on that okay in
other words nobody does uh physical
interpretations and uh the worst part is
that they dismiss that as
philosophy they say I don't I don't we
we do
equations but then it's my
million-dollar
question if they just do equations if
it's not part of their job description
to give you a physical interpretation if
they don't do physic um philosophy of
physics philosophy of science whatever
they want to call it if they dismiss
that as philosophy if it's not part of
their job description why did they even
why did they even
attempt to give you a physical
interpretation why didn't they just stay
with math and say you know this this is
what we do we do equations and math and
uh describe no problem I have no problem
with that it's when they cross the line
into physics and they say oh let me tell
you how the universe works okay how does
it work well you have all these
particles and they do all this magic but
you cannot explain it yeah but that's
philosophy anyways we we do math we got
a contradiction because if you don't do
physical interpretations don't do them
don't do them don't don't jump the fence
and try to do physics when you're not
doing physics when you can't do physics
because you in the end you say well it's
philosophy anyways that's not part of
our job description that's where the
problem is these people are telling you
they know how the universe works through
their math right because otherwise their
math would be completely
irrelevant if they cannot tell you how
the universe works how gravity Works how
light does its magic they cannot explain
that in a rational manner then their
their equations are worthless that's why
they try to give you a physical
interpretation when you call their Bluff
they jump back the fence they say well
we don't do that that's on the other
side of the fence anyways that's
philosophy that's the problem there's
that's where the contradiction is
okay so what does he have to say about
light okay here it is neither the wave
Viewpoint nor the particle Viewpoint is
correct aha we would always like to
present things accurately or at least
precisely enough that they will not have
to be changed but when we try to talk
about the wave picture or the particle
picture both will change therefore what
we learn will not be accurate we will
deal with some half inuitive arguments
in other words he has no intuition
meaning he has no proposal for what
light is because that's where you got to
start okay here we say here it is that's
what light is light is torsion along a
physical entity a physical entity not a
concept not a mathematical abstraction
it's a physical object that you know
that um binds any two atoms my fists
here serve as atoms hydrogen atoms okay
and what light is a torsion now we have
a torsion now we going to explain why
light is so fast because a torsion wave
is faster than any transverse or um long
longitudinal wave okay uh or any kind of
wave for that matter you know U uh you
have one-dimensional or two-dimensional
waves this is a 3D wave okay so it's a
torsion and it's the fastest thing you
can imagine nothing is faster than a
torsion wave out there okay torsion is
fast because the the object is already
connected at two ends to the two atoms
so you nothing has to travel all you do
is torque and the signal is what is
detected by the other atom it's a thump
that it receives okay and that's why
light is so fast now we can explain the
speed of light why it's so fast okay but
yeah if you're going to try to do with
particles not only are they One Way
whereas a torsion Works two ways right
uh or you know the standard wave you
know where you to take the standing wave
or any kind of wave for that matter
other than the torsion wave you have a
one-way wave oneway particle One Way
wave and you cannot explain how the
universe works with any of those two
okay okay what does he have to say about
energy well that's very quick here I've
said it many times it is important to
realize that in physics today we have no
knowledge of
what energy is well good old uh pinman
didn't realize that energy was not a
what neither has any mathematician since
then energy is not a what energy is a
concept what's are objects an object is
a what so you can point to it but you
can't point to energy because energy is
a mathematical concept and he never
realize that so he's trying to figure
out what is
energy I thought you didn't do physical
interpretations dicki okay okay and then
energy the capacity that's what it is
the ability
that's how it's defined and so yeah the
capacity is not a physical object
neither is the
ability and then what did he have to say
about gravity and remember quantum
mechanics has no idea what gravity is so
he says uh what is gravity in his
lectures right what about the ma
Machinery of it all we have done is to
describe how the Earth moves around the
Sun but we have not said what makes it
go yeah that's what we want to know
Newton made no hypothesis about this he
was satisfied to find what it did
without getting into the Machinery of it
it's not that he didn't Newton tried to
figure out how it works you know why it
works the way it does in other words he
wanted to figure out the mechanism but
he was thinking of particles also he was
a you know an ether guy he believed in
The Ether particles bunch of particles
and he could not explain it with
particles so he says you know it just
blows my mind how this could be
happening yeah if you propose particles
you cannot explain it Newton couldn't
explain it but he says you know he did
not delve upon that yeah he did he did
but he just couldn't explain it and
neither can good old Dicky here right so
one has uh since given so no one has
since given any Machinery yeah they've
given a Machinery not in Quantum but in
general relativity but it's an
irrational one they're saying that um
there's this
thingy concept mathematic iCal concept
called SpaceTime and it bends a concept
that bends man that's that's
deep a concept that bend you know it's
like love bending you know intelligence
bending you know data bending you know
it is characteristic of the physical
laws that they have this abstract
character huh yeah no they don't have as
abstract character only in Quant in
mathematics do they have abstract
characters the law of conservation of
energy is a theorem concerning Quant uh
quantities that have to be calculated
and added together again they're talking
math they're not talking about physics
with no mention of the Machinery right
because Machinery is physics right and
likewise the great laws of mechanics are
quantitative mathematical laws for which
no Machinery is available yeah uh
because they have the math the equation
they have the measurements but they
don't have the proper assumption itions
about the invisible mediators or objects
that mediate you know the transactions
the phenomena why can we use mathematics
to describe nature without a mechanism
behind it no one knows yeah if you don't
have the right U assumption the right
hypothesis as it's called the right
objects the right mediators you're not
going to explain it you're never going
to be able to explain it okay so one
fellow asks about uh question related to
good old findan says uh we assume that
the electron is a ball indivisible that
it is not composed of other objects but
that it is unique and uniform in other
words what he's saying is that it's made
of a single piece in short that's how we
say it in physics it's made out of a
single piece period this ball spins on
itself they call it
spin this ball turns and turns but it
always shows the same face the same
surface properties the same side I
wonder if it turns or if it is
still and uh so good old dicki also you
know talked about spin okay and um here
it is he says spin should not be
conceptualized as involving the rotation
of a particle's internal mass as
ordinary use of the word may suggest
spin is a quantized property of waves so
it's a wave that is spinning so it's not
a ball that's the first one you know the
very earliest models for for electron
spin imagine a rotating charged Mass
yeah mass is not a is also a concept so
we don't we don't have mass mass cannot
rotate a ball can rotate not a number
not a mathematical concept but this
model fails when examined in detail no
kidding the required space distribution
do does not match limits on the electron
radius the required rotation speed
exceeds the speed of light aha see that
that's part of the problem why they
cannot explain this the classical analog
for Quantum spin is a is a circulation
of
energy CC energy circulates I mean you
know what is it a smoke what is this
energy thingy or momentum density in a
particle wave field spin is essentially
a wave property as the name suggests
spin was originally conceived as the
rotation of a particle around some axis
yeah that's what we think uh spin means
right historically orbital angular
moment
related to particle orbits while the
names based on mechanical models have
survived the physical explanation has
not right because you can't rotate
numbers you can't spin numbers or you
know quantities or abstractions
quantization fundamentally Alters the
character of both Spin and orbital
angular momentum since elementary
particles are Point likee self rotation
is not well defined for them yeah what
is the What is the problem with this um
spin thingy that Quantum has well uh
again first I I cannot imagine how they
can
conceive of a wave spinning especially a
transverse wave because a transvers wave
is made of two Fields you know the light
it's made of two Fields uh at 90 degrees
to each other and each field is just
made of vectors so what are we talking
about we're talking about numbers that
are rotating that's the problem that's
where it starts now you need a physical
object you can say that a ball spins you
can talk about this spinning okay but
what's the problem to answer this F's
question if this is made out of a single
piece you canot say it rotates because
in order to rotate you need at least two
things you need a center point and an
edge point if this is made out of a
single piece meaning very s small tiny
thing made out of single piece you
cannot imagine it rotating you cannot
conceptualize it rotating because the
only way going to imagine something like
that happening is if the point on the
outside Compares against a point on the
inside and if it's made out of a single
piece you you're going to try to imagine
that as a ball made out of particles
where you have two particles and one is
rotating around the other so you cannot
have spin in an object made of a single
piece and no one in mathematics ever
resolve that and that's why they use the
word spin they illustrate spin as
spinning is a top spinning but then they
tell you that's not
spin what do you mean uh spin spin or is
spin not spin and they say what it is
spin uh so we illustrate it that way but
don't take the analogy so
literally okay with that I'll see you
next week and hopefully I'll get rid of
some of